it's far harder working in the kitchen
with a blunt knife than it is with a
sharp knife the secret behind keeping a
sharp knife
sharpen it before and every time you use
it first grip the steel feel really
comfortable about holding the still
imagine you're holding a tennis racquet
or you're playing squash you've got to
be really comfortable with it now 45
degrees confident grip confident grip
with a knife this is the butt of the
steel really important to keep your
fingers behind there you never grip a
steel with your fingers over that
because the knife comes back in you've
just lost a finger always grip behind
nice long strokes so we get the whole of
the blade
over still
stroke
and we start from the bottom to the top
so there
across
there
across
slow strokes over the top of the steel
and then come back underneath
then back underneath
it is so dangerous working in the
kitchen with a blunt knife you can cause
so much damage working with a sharp
knife is 10 times quicker more efficient
now
that's ready to start chopping
to stop your chopping board rocking or
slipping a great tip is to simply wet a
kitchen cloth kitchen paper or tea towel
and place it underneath
[Music]
now you can chop with confidence
[Music]
my next top tip is get the most out of
your humble veg peeler
it's brilliant for slicing ultra-thin
ribbons of veg perfect for asian dishes
great for making long delicate parmesan
shavings to top soups and salads
it also makes wonderful chocolate curls
your pepper mill is more versatile than
you might think
tighten the top screw to get finely
ground pepper ideal for soups and sauces
[Music]
for general seasoning you want it medium
ground so set the screw in the middle
and loosen it right off for coarse
pepper perfect for steaks and fish
[Music]
peeling garlic for one clove simply bash
it with the back of a knife and the skin
comes off
easily for a whole head crush separate
into a bowl
cover and shake hard for about 10
seconds
then simply pick out the peeled cloves
basically three knives a heavy duty
chopping knife
followed by a small paring knife which
is brilliant for prepping vegetables
and then this baby here a serrated edge
knife for carving and slicing
basically that is it
before you buy a knife hold it in your
hand and make sure it feels right for
you
the secret behind a great set of knives
is in the handle if you're comfortable
holding the handle
your cutting can be so much easier the
firmer the grip the better the chopping
the heavier the handle the more control
you've got over the blade
with these three knives you can't go
wrong
this is the root that's absolutely
crucial leave that on there if you cut
that off the onion will start to bleed
and you'll start crying rapidly
slice going forward let the weight of
the knife do the work
three fingers
one in front two behind and this part of
the knuckle is going to guide the knife
fingers on top of the onion point the
knife towards the root and try to get
as close to the root as possible nice
long
stroke
and then push the onion back together
push the knife halfway in to the onion
slightly tilt the knife down
one at the top
and then gripping the onion like a
tennis ball holding it together in place
with the weight of the blade to cut
through that onion to get to the base of
the root
again turn it round
up and down motion
and that's what we're left there no
waste just the root
and look
there you've got a really nice finely
chopped onion
so much great cooking depends on
starting with a high enough heat if a
recipe calls for a hot pan put on early
so it gets smoking hot and always
remember to preheat your oven at least
20 minutes before cooking
a clean cook is an efficient cook my tip
for a tidy cooking area is to always
have a waste bowl next to you it saves
you going back and forth to the bin
saucepans i mean basically you don't
need a collection of ten all you need
really is two a medium-sized one
followed by a large one a small pan is
great for sauces heating liquids or rice
whereas your large pan gives you space
perfect for pastas stews or when you're
cooking in bulk which keeps costs down
made from copper to stainless steel find
what's right for you and always get a
lid which helps heat the pan up as
quickly as possible
and the secret behind a great saucepan
is
the heavier the bottom the more heat it
will conduct
the thinner the bottom the more chance
you've got actually burning your food
buy the best saucepans you can afford
take good care of them and they'll last
you years saving you money in the long
run
casserole dish absolutely essential when
it comes to good home cooking why so
versatile the beauty of this thing is
the fact that you can actually use it on
the hob or start it on the hob and
finish it in the oven more importantly
cast iron it conducts the heat so you
can have the gas on absolute minimal or
the oven down to its absolute lowest
setting and the thing will just cook
naturally casserole dishes are
surprisingly versatile and a great
investment you only need one and if you
look after it it'll last you a lifetime
brilliant
for one pot wonders
roasting and baking tray
these things so versatile great for
baking whole fish on fantastic for
making breads and so cheap
a classic two-handled roasting tray
brilliant for roasting whole birds
finishing
sauces gravies on top of the stove over
the gastering burner
again versatile
the more solid your trays are the better
then they won't buckle and they will
last cheap but seriously essential
hull hams are always impressive to carve
one easily hold the hand by the bone and
cut down the meat as close to the bone
as possible
you can then lay your cut hand flat on
the board making it nice and easy to
slice thinly and evenly
for perfect pork crackling pour over hot
oil before roasting in the oven it'll
come out beautifully crisp and crunchy
and when you need to chill wine fast
simply add a large handful of salt to
your ice bucket the salt reduces the
freezing point of the water which will
chill your wine in six minutes flat
flavor
chopping herbs the secret is to chop
them not bruise them now basil
this is a soft herb so treat it with
some respect when people go mad chopping
herbs all the goodness comes out on the
board i want the goodness left inside
the basil place them all inside one
another with the largest
leaf at the bottom and it's almost like
rolling a cigar
large one at the bottom small ones in
the center
and then look place them down together
and just roll them
nice and gently don't bruise them
step one
rolled ready to slice sharp knife
imperative fingers
tucked in
the bottom part of your knuckle is the
guide between you and the herbs
that there
stops you from cutting your finger
really important to get comfortable with
a knife and just practice rolling the
knife across the board and relaxing that
wrist it's all in the wrist action so
herbs
up
fingernails tucked
underneath and just up and down
up and down
and there you have
a chopped basil that's not bruised
and smelling very
fragra right coriander so you get the
bunch of coriander hold it down
and just lightly shave
the leaves
off the stalks
bunch them up together and then just
again let the knife do the work take the
fingernails in and just chop once
and once only don't
hack it
just chop it you can always identify
when you bruise the herb when you've
removed the herbs off the board there's
a big green patch
mmm
full of flavour and none of the goodness
is left on the chopping board
a great tip for using leftover herbs
simply chop finely mix into butter roll
up in clim film and freeze
then when you want a herbie hit cut into
slices and melt over steaks chicken or
veg
asparagus is great for a simple supper
to prepare always remove the lower woody
stem by gently bending and the asparagus
will snap at the perfect point
then boil or steam and serve with a
little of my herb butter
when slow roasting meat line the bottom
of the roasting tray with chunky
vegetables like onions fennel and
carrots they act as a trivet to keep the
meat from boiling in its own juices plus
the veg can be the base for your gravy
later on
after slow cooking baked on residue can
be tough to remove but if you boil water
in the pan it will dissolve and break
down then simply pour out and wash with
soap and water
for perfect boiled potatoes always start
them off in cold water and never boiling
water this way by the time the centers
of the potatoes are cooked the outside
won't be falling apart chicken stock the
vital ingredient to good cooking it
transforms sauces it's a fantastic base
for soups and more importantly it's so
easy to do a little bit of love and care
at the beginning and it cooks itself
right step one
chicken carcass into a pie-sided pan an
onion
doesn't need to be finely chopped the
vegetables flavor the stock
onion in
then from there cut your leek into nice
big solid chunks roughly
same size as the onion
so the vegetables cook at the same time
and then our carrot
celery in
garlic
and then
a nice
sprig of thyme that helps to really give
depth of flavor to the chicken stock a
couple of bay leaves
and some fresh parsley
and then
peppercorns
pan
and just lightly crush them
and a little pinch of salt
and now just cover the vegetables and
the carcass with cold water
just cover the chicken
and the vegetables
bring it up to the ball as quick as you
can
now as it comes into the boil a really
nice skin
take the base of the ladle and swirl
that around that pushes
all the grease and the impurities to the
side of the pan then get your ladle and
just tilt it
if you don't skim all that off
the stock becomes very cloudy
people's impression of cooking stock
then it needs to cook for three four
hours at a time this is one chicken
carcass let that boil away gently for 30
to 40 minutes maximum
now
we're gonna pass it off
take a sieve
place that over
the pan
and then just
pour that in
it smells amazing
it's aromatic
the color is absolutely beautiful
and there you have
the most amazing stock